So yesterday CNN did this climate change forum.
They had back to back town halls.
I think it went seven hours in total, each
candidate or many of the candidates.
I don't have the full list of who even participated
in front of me.
As I mentioned, I just dipped in and out of
a few minutes here, there and then read a
summary.
Uh, the idea was let's go deep.
Let's go deep with each candidate on climate
change.
And one issue that keeps coming up time and
again and Elizabeth Warren handled that really
well, is this topic of plastic straws and
light bulbs and plastic straws and light bulbs
are a bogus distraction to the broader systemic
changes that need to happen in order to really
deal with the climate crisis.
So there's a really good analogy here, and
it's undocumented immigration and wages.
This has been waged effectively by huge corporations.
Huge corporations really are what keep wages
down.
Huge corporations take advantage of undocumented
immigrant labor who is less likely to push
back against bad working conditions because
they know they're undocumented and they know
that they risk if they start reporting things
and getting on law enforcement's radar, they
just risk deportation.
So it is really corporations that have to
be blamed for perpetuating and even encouraging
the status quo around immigration.
But corporations have done something genius.
They have fomented the idea that the middle
class in America and the lower middle class
blue collar workers, they need to be at odds
with Latin American immigrants.
They by fighting with each other are lowering
wages and blah blah, blah, blah blah.
And it has worked brilliantly because very
infrequently do you seriously hear the corporate
responsibility addressed when it comes to
keeping wages.
You've got workers fighting workers and that's
exactly what corporations want.
Apply that to climate change.
The building industry, the electric power
industry and the oil industry are some of
the biggest polluters and biggest sources
of fossil fuel emissions.
And yet they, through corporate PR campaigns
have brilliantly put the focus on have you
so switched off of plastic straws to the paper
straws or compostable potato starch straws
or whatever.
Have you replaced all of your light bulbs
with the cfls which lasts however long it
is or whatever.
And Elizabeth Warren was asked about this
during her climate change town hall on CNN
and she brilliantly called it out.
But do you think that the government should
be in the business of telling you what kind
of light bulb you can have?
Oh, come on, give me a break.
You know that?
Yes.
No, look, there are a lot of ways that we
try to change our energy consumption and our
pollution and God bless all of those ways.
Some of it is with light bulbs, some of it
is on straws, some of it Dang is on cheeseburgers,
right?
There are a lot of different pieces to this.
And I get that people are trying to find the
part that they can work on and what can they
do?
And I'm in favor of that and I'm going to
help and I'm going to support.
But understand this is exactly what the fossil
fuel industry helps we're all talking about.
That's what they want us to talk about.
This is no problem.
They want to be able to stir up a lot of controversy
around your light bulbs, around your straws
and around your cheeseburgers.
When 70% of the pollution of the carbon that
we're throwing into the air comes from three
industries and we can set our targets and
say by 2028 2030 and 2035 no more.
Think about that right there.
Now the other 30% we still gotta work on
this is the answer.
We can't let these bad actors do the sense-making.
To borrow a term from earlier in the show,
something like 100 companies are responsible
for 71% of global emissions.
Framing is extremely important when you look
at the discussion of Medicare for all we talk
about the economic benefits.
We talk about the emotional, psychological
benefits of not having to worry about if I
get treatment or if I get sick, am I going
to go bankrupt?
There's all these intangible benefits to something
that is affordable.
We've seen it time and again it is affordable,
but you will hear this concern trolling of,
but, but if we do medicare for all, some people
will lose jobs.
Medical coders and insurance fraud investigators
and medical billing people, those are jobs
that should not have existed in the first
place.
I've addressed this issue already.
Anytime government does anything, there is
a job impact.
Even policies that create 10,000 jobs might
simultaneously destroy 500 meaning that the
net benefit is only 9,500 jobs.
It's a red herring.
Okay?
It is the idea of putting pressure on people
to fight against each other for the benefit
of corporations and we can't be distracted
by this stuff.
Fuel efficiency of cars is another one.
Listen, if you can go from cars on average
getting 10 miles per gallon to 60 miles per
gallon, I'm not pretending that that's not
going to have an impact.
But when you look at vehicles versus cargo
ships and aviation and all of this other stuff,
it is again pressuring the consumer to believe
that they are the ones who need to solve the
problem by not using a plastic straw or by
getting a hybrid vehicle or for whatever the
case may be.
And the whole point of it is prevent demand
for corporate action.
And the way to do that is prevent demand for
government regulation of corporations, which
is the answer.
I mean that's just, that is the answer and
that's where we need to be looking.
That's why the narrative and agenda setting
power of corporate media is so important and
we can't let them do it.
Good for Elizabeth Warren for shutting it
down.